القائد الذي يعرف الواقع أفضل
من أي شخص آخر الآن على الأقل في
نيويورك هو حاكم نيويورك أندرو
كومو بالطبع أشكرك أخي على
عودتك إلى العرض ،
أخبرتني أمي أنني يجب أن أفعل الشيء الوحيد الذي
حدث هنا هو  لقد تغيرت العدسة ، فأنا
أفعل ما أفعله وكنت أفعل
ذلك بنفس الطريقة وأنا أبدو كما كنت
دائمًا أبدو الأمر الذي سيكون عادلاً ،
لكنك تستمع إلى أنني سأصل إلى
ذلك  أنا أسمع أظافرك
مثل الخدش على شيء كأنك
متوتر ، أعلم أنك مشغول هناك
دائمًا وقت لقص
أظافرك والاتصال بوالدتك لأنك تعلم أن
ما يقوله الناس عن مظهرك
لا يمكن أن يكون حقًا  دقيق ، لذلك يجب أن يكون من
الصعب عليك فهم ما هو
حقيقي وما هو حقيقي الآن أشعر بأنك
الرئيس التنفيذي لشركة la jello لتقول مرحبًا ، انظر ER أنت
تعلم أن جيف دائمًا ما يكون مستقيمًا
عبر اللوحة مباشرة عبر اللوحة ،
القليل من المخدرات لا تفعل  قلق لا يزال هناك
وقت هذا الأمل بالنسبة لك يومًا ما يمكنني أن أكبر
لأكون مثل  لقد حاولت أن أكون
مثلك طوال حياتي ،
انظر إلى المكان الذي أوصلني إليه الحاكم أندرو
كومو ، شكرًا جزيلاً لك على القيام بعمل
أفضل ، شكرًا لك على رعاية
الأسرة التي أحبك ، سأتحدث إليك
أفضل من صنع لأفضل من  أنا
فقط في ملعب كرة السلة
لا أكذب أبدًا ، هذا ما قاله البوب
ًا لم يفعل ما رآه لم
هزمني أبدًا لماذا لا نريده قا
أندرو لديه قدرة هائلة إن
مبارك من نواح كثيرة لكنه  حصلت على
أيادي مثل الموز ولا يمكنه لعب
الكرة ، الجميع يعرف ذلك فقط يقولها
مع صاحب المال
المتدرج وسأخرجك وأصفعك ، تعلم
أين أعيش ، سأراك قريبًا ستصبح
حاكمًا جيدًا أحبك أنا  لا تحبه
التوتر حقيقي بالرغم من ذلك